you've heard me earlier talk on the
angle about how the Democrats are
clinging desperately the death grip on
this victimhood narrative but how does
that impact the african-american
community the community at large joining
me now with answers
Bruce Levin he's executive director of
the national diversity Coalition for
Trump and Henry Davis founder and
president of the conservative urban
project who is in DC for the celebration
of Black History Month both of you it's
great to have you on Bruce let's start
with you so we got here we got we got
Jesse makes 125k a year by the way yeah
the police make 48k year yeah like Bruce
does there's not enough money so you got
to get a couple guys to come back Laura
this kind of keeps playing into the same
old thing here and I are talking about
this in agreement about how the left
always tries to portray black folks like
us yet our to intimidate us you know
I've always said this is the biggest
voter suppression in the land the way
the left they'll put this is a this is
another example to scare the book bad
big boogeyman of America don't go over
there they're bad people et cetera but
the disheartening part of it more than
anything lore is we yeah we we've had
some issues in the back we've come a
long way look at the president tonight
oh my god tonight he was so unfired oh
my god got some president Trump you are
killing it tonight he was so excited we
have African American History Month he
was celebrating PAC jam room yeah
screaming loud he was so happy the fact
that we have the lowest black
unemployment you don't have all these
great initiatives the hundred billion
dollars going into opportunities owns
all this positive press and then here we
go
Jesse the reason though Henry isn't that
precisely why they're selling this
you're oppressed you're a victim watch
out for the the guys with the red hats
because they're coming for you I mean
it's the worst kind of scare tackle but
they're doing it because precisely
because things are getting better well I
first of all I really don't even
understand why so many people hate black
people what people that look like me and
him hate this president because this man
has done more than any other president
has done for people that look like me
and him and then
ever I were to make a hat wherever I go
I walk around st. Louis with my gold
Trump Trump across all cuz these are you
gonna put Trump or you gonna cry
and this thing about goods named Josie
just Lord Herbert look Josie Josie just
need to go ahead and sit down somewhere
in his sale get some people put some
money on his books and you know fix him
some ramen noodles and some and then
he'll really be part we know what by the
way I know both of you are very big
Elizabeth Warren fans but oh it change
the subject away from Jessie to how the
Democrats are going to help the
african-american community something
that Trump apparently won't do let's
watch it's a full screen sorry about
that she says we must confront the dark
history of slavery and government
sanctioned discrimination in this
country that has had many consequences
she continues including undermining the
ability of black families to build
wealth in America for generations we
need systemic structural changes to
address that and she's talking about
reparations Xena would write a check
write a check she'd done by the
Democrats that's what the Democrats are
doing to us that's what that's what will
that's why we ask people that look like
me and him are in the position that
we're in is because of the Democrats I'm
trying to tell you right now Laura I
look Donald Trump is the most Pro and
this is a quote from my friend pastor
Daryl Scott who I'll be working with him
and Kareem on the urban revitalization
coalition and when they come to st.
Louis I'd say that real quick Donald
Trump is the most Pro black president
that we have ever seen and I like to
enter fide they are petrified of Donald
Trump going even 5% of the black vote
away Kanye West I think it was Kanye
West said get off that plantation is he
right he said don't be stay on that
Democrat plantation oh here we go again
voter suppression let's throw the the
bid back boogie man into the room and
intimidate us Laureus is serious stuff
you know you know at the end of the day
you know I the President Trump is going
to be the champion that guys it look
like like us to build generational
wealth yes America you better say like
as
ever been done before like myself I'm a
27 year business owner in Atlanta
there's many guys like me many of us
around the country that want that
opportunity this president I co-signed
with to Pastor Scott he will be the best
is the best president well you better
say history history two words victimhood
what do you tell the african-american
kid out there watching maybe he's a 20
year old watch him and they say you're a
victim you say to him that's a lie
first like I did oh that exactly that's
what I see that's a lot numbers don't
lie I always say don't get caught up in
the emotions and I say this on every
I've been on all these other networks
and I always say this for black America
don't get caught up in the moment about
the s whole country's comment and what
about well you know it's always that
solution don't pay bills that don't
build that do anything except keep this
junk going here has no president Trump
ain't scared
I see did you know he bought that life
he got that he got that